let's wrap up DreamWorks you weary with
Madagascar three the third and
presumably last in the Madagascar movies
and I have to say this seems like a
series of movies that just keeps getting
better and better
the first one was funny the second one
was really funny the third one is just
constantly hilarious except when needs
to be heartfelt and sentimental and it
does that very very well it has the same
great characters the same great energy
the same great animation and a whole
bunch of visual wonder the story starts
off much like the last one exactly where
it left off our crew is still stuck in
Africa but the Penguins have apparently
taken the plane and gone to Europe to
try and find help but it seems they've
been taking too long so the animals
decide to take matters into their own
hands and just go to Europe themselves
which is strange why didn't they go
there before a car to logic it runs on
car to logic they catch the Penguins
gambling and tried to take their
winnings to get a ride back home but the
police is called on them and a fearsome
creature named la Capitan du Bois is on
a quest to add the missing part of her
collection a lion she obsesses over
getting her prize and will stop at
nothing until the lion's head is hers
trying to find a way to escape the
animals find a circus train and sneak on
board but in order for them not to blow
their cover they say that there's circus
animals and thus the circus train
welcomes them aboard thinking they can
use this as a means to get back home
they buy the circus with the money they
have and see if they can use their
talents to work their way back to the
city the only problem is the circus
stinks they used to have a lot of great
talents onboard but most of them have
fallen flat in the past few years so
it's up to our main characters to try
and get the circus back on track while
also avoiding the watchful eye of luck a
Pathan not only did this movie have the
most last but I think it also had the
most funny characters as Frances
McDormand Locke a Piton and honestly you
can never tell she just gets lost in the
role and you're too busy laughing at her
in order to figure out that it's
actually her playing it cuz no one is
appearing and that's also Martin Short
as an Italian seal and again you would
never know he just does such a great job
you would never figure it out what pains
him
knock on door hey I have a great idea
maybe you're coming with us - no hey
Vitaly is it just a playground okay the
words are the actors once again just do
great and reprising these roles and
being incredibly entertaining and giving
great deliveries and once again they do
great and balancing out the heartfelt
moments as well including a circus
performer that used to be the top of the
world but has since then become afraid
even terrified of letting people down
with his stunts that he doesn't think
and work anymore now it's true the story
does work its way I guess into the
inevitable liar reveal plot which a lie
you know I really despise but hey they
don't focus on it very long and be in
this story it sort of works there's a
very surprising yet genuine twist when
they get back to their home and taking
into account everything they've gone
through in the other movies you'd almost
swear this was planned like they knew
they were gonna do this from the start
now the only R element that might be a
little distracting is this movie was
shot in 3d and well it's not as bad as
other 3d films that like to show off
their technology this one definitely
does get some weird shots at times not
quite to the point where it's
distracting but you can definitely kind
of take notice but in other scenes it's
so visually interesting and incredibly
colorful you don't mind the actual
performance of the circus when they get
it perfected is just wonderful to look
at its imaginative its musical it's
upbeat it's energetic I hadn't quite
seen anything like then the other two
madagascar films and that's one of the
reasons i think this one's the best but
that's not the only reason the
characters still work great off each
other it has a great villain it has
great side characters and as good drama
it has good comedy it has good visuals
it has funny subplots everything about
it just seems to work out perfectly I
really do hope they stop here because I
don't think they could top it after this
it seemed like every film was getting
closer and closer to that wild yet
really imaginative comedy and here I
think it's perfected while also having
some characters you really do care about
and you want to see them get through
their predicament films like these make
me really happy that did DreamWorks you
worried cuz honestly I probably won't
have seen them it shows you this series
of films you think is just getting worse
and worse sometimes it turns out it's
just getting better and better and
speaking of better and better I hope
that dream worse does nothing but
do that with its animated films they've
been creative they've been inspiring
they've been dramatic they've opened up
the doors to all sorts of new realms of
imagination
it's been great reviewing them at all I
can say is I hope to see more great
products in the future
three two one